[Music]
okay bonus round this question here
looks disastrous uh you know we haven't
really been thinking too much about
trigonometric identities for a while
but we can solve this trigonometric
identity with complex numbers thrown
into it
if we take care with the complex
arithmetic that we've just used and also
um use a few of the very basic trig
identities that actually come from the
advanced course not even extension one
so
let's have a go at this guy now you can
see
we've got this left hand side we need to
prove this equal to the right hand side
and it is customary to start with one
side and prove it equal to the other
and you can sort of choose which one is
which in a rare number of occasions
sometimes it's not clear which one the
left hand or the right hand you want to
start with but in this case
it's pretty obvious i think our brains
are much better at simplifying
complicated things
than complicating simple things we've
been telling you for years to simplify
so therefore i'm going to start
with the left hand side because it's the
more messy one
so what have i got here um a messy
looking fraction for sure
you've got this on the numerator and
then here comes the denominator
now what i'm going to do even though
this looks like a complicated mess
especially because of all this trig
that's floating around
i'm just going to use a technique that
we've been using in the previous
questions with complex arithmetic which
is
how you deal with a fraction that has a
complex denominator
answer get rid of the complexness of the
denominator we want to
realize this denominator now even though
it looks messy
this is still just a real component
with an imaginary component
so therefore to identify the conjugate
of this is not that difficult
i'm just going to take the real part
it's left alone
and then the imaginary part instead of
the minus i'm going to take the
opposite sign so it's a plus right now
in this case
and it's not a coincidence the actual
conjugate of my denominator down here
happens to be the exact same thing
as my numerator can you see there you've
got the same
let me get the right color you've got
the same real part there one plus
sine theta and then you have the
imaginary part which is
opposite in sine plus i cos theta rather
than
minus so therefore i'm going to multiply
the top and the bottom
by that let's do it this way because i'm
not actually changing the fraction
and i'll do my fraction like so so now
i'm going to
multiply through okay now what's going
to happen well
take care this is going to get worse
before it gets better
let's see what we end up with i'm going
to write this as
1 plus i sorry 1 plus sine theta
there's my real component plus i cos
theta and that whole thing is being
squared and then on the denominator
let's write that like so because i chose
the conjugate i'm going to get
difference of squares or sum of squares
if you want to think about it that way
on the numerator that was the whole
point right so if i call this my
a minus b and this is my a plus
b we're familiar with the fact that
we're expecting a squared minus b
squared on the denominator so what's
a squared minus b squared going to look
like well here comes a squared this is
a 1 plus sine theta so there's a squared
and then i'm going to subtract b squared
which in this case is i
cos theta that thing is squared you can
see that
i in the denominator right there that's
going to come out and factorize and be
an i
squared so that gives me this plus so
what do we get
on the top and the bottom and how do
things start to simplify out
i'm going to take the real part and the
imaginary part of
the numerator and here and here and i'm
going to treat them separately so you
can see
i'm going to get 1 plus sine theta
squared i'm going to as i've been doing
in the past we're going to do the a
squared and then the b
squared so here comes b squared
and you should recognize this from the
denominator we just dealt with and then
i'm going to add 2
a b which in this case is 2 i cos theta
1 plus sine theta so there is my
expansion of the numerator it's not
finished yet as you can see i have i
have these things flying around
um but i will be able to deal with them
in a second before i even get started on
the
denominator can i point out how obvious
it is that our algebra skills from
advanced and also that we work on in
extension
how important they are to doing
questions like this they're kind of
assumed knowledge and if that's the part
you're struggling with
then the new part of this the complex
part of it
will just be completely lost on us so
you have to take great care
to make sure you don't make any little
mistakes with like minus signs or things
like that
okay so there's my numerator dealt with
i might move that a little further down
so you can see some separation like so
that's better
what happens with our denominator well
i'm going to get
1 plus sine theta i'm going to start to
square this whole thing out okay
so i'm going to get 1 which is 1 squared
i'm going to get my 2 a b which is in
this case 2
times 1 times sine theta so 2 sine theta
plus sine squared theta there we go
there's my 1 plus sine theta all squared
and then
here because i've got this i squared and
then a cos
squared this minus and this i squared
are going to cancel
so there's a double negative right so
it's just going to give me plus
cos squared and so
even though we had these very long
things to cancel this is not looking too
unreasonable because hopefully
the gears are starting to turn in your
head and you're starting to recognize
things like this guy here which is an
identity
that we can simplify fairly easily so
we're going to come to this shortly
all right now while i'm working on this
i can see that this expansion that i did
here
this expansion that i did here is
identical to one that's on the numerator
up there so i might as well just save my
brain some effort and just write that
same thing all out again i'm going to
write 1 plus
2 sine theta plus
cos uh sorry what am i doing i'm already
going on to the next term this is a sine
squared theta okay
and then my next term because it's plus
i
cos theta being squared it's going to
become minus
cos squared like so so i hope you can
see i just highlighted to make it really
uh clear that you're going to get this
will do this guy
here becomes this guy here the
i squared let's do a dotted so it
doesn't interfere too much
that i squared has become that negative
1 and then the cos
or squared is just i've just written
this cos squared ok so that looks good
then on the end here i've got i'm going
to bring out that i
because you can see that's you usually
separate out the imaginary part and then
see what the coefficient is
and then you get left with uh cos theta
in fact i'll even write the cos theta
here
multiply by 1 plus sine theta now you
might think
i'm expanding all this other stuff on
the numerator why aren't i expanding
this
one plus sine theta as well well i'm
trying to
look ahead to things that are going to
cancel and i'm trying to
when i do any trigonometric identity
proof always have
one eye on the destination as well as
one eye on what i'm working on right now
and if you think back
to what i was doing over here this this
is the the end result i'm hoping for
this one plus sine theta is kind of it
sort of doesn't belong
i'm sort of anticipating and hoping that
if i do my algebra correctly
this is going to end up cancelling out
so that's why i'm going to leave it
factorized if of course you didn't know
that and you just expand it anyway
that's okay
you're just going to have to
re-factorize afterwards when you realize
you want some cancelling to happen all
right
so there's the state of the numerator
like so the denominator now like i
mentioned
you've got this sine squared plus cos
squared which just equals
1. so that's really great that one will
combine with this
one so that leaves me with two plus two
sine
theta and you can see why i was
anticipating this one plus sine theta
is going to hopefully do some cancelling
down here
we're not quite there yet though we need
to deal with what's happening
up here i've got sine squared minus cos
squared so that's that's not going to
become 1 like this is what do we do here
well remembering that i'll put off
another color over here
remembering that we've just used this
fact that sine squared theta
plus cos squared theta it equals 1.
i can rearrange this and make cos
squared a subject you can see i can just
subtract sine squared from both sides
that gives me this so what i can do is i
can substitute this
cos squared i can substitute that into
this spot over here so what does that
leave me with on the numerator
it's going to be 1 plus 2 sine theta
plus sine squared that hasn't changed
but then i'm going to subtract
1 minus sine squared theta you can see
the attraction of this
i've got sine squared on the numerator
that i can i can cancel with other stuff
so
now i can collect some like terms here
and that's going to be simpler for me
this guy here i have not can't i've not
changed not cancelled or factorized or
done anything like that
and i haven't done anything to the
denominator either
though i might as well while i'm at it i
might as well factor out
that 2 because it appears twice so i get
if i can correct the pick that thing two
outside of one plus sine theta okay
things are looking good we're actually
making some progress here
what's going to happen up here let's use
some colors i referenced this in class
the other day
colors really help you to see what's
going on let's pick a color i haven't
used yet
this one which is one of the only like
just
normal numbers up there on the numerator
is going to cancel with this minus 1. so
they're just going to
disappear that's really really nice and
then i've got this
sine squared which is going to not
cancel but
add to this sine squared because you can
see i've got a negative and a negative
so this becomes
plus sine squared so what does that
leave me with i've got a 2 sine theta
out the front i've now got 2 lots of
sine
squared theta and that's everything
from from this term here it's all being
cancelled out or collected
so that leaves me with this guy over
here
and my uh my denominator hasn't changed
much either so i'll just
leave that like so and i don't need such
a
a long fraction line there which is
looking really good
all right how things going to go now
well i've got factors of 2 everywhere so
that's great i'm going to
cancel all of those with the 2 on the
denominator
and then you can see tantalizingly i
have this
1 plus sine theta here and a 1 plus sine
theta here
but i don't have the one plus sine theta
all over the numerator so i need to do a
little bit of extra
simplifying you can see if i look
carefully at these two terms here sine
theta
plus sine squared if you factor out a
sine theta
what do you get left with lo and behold
a really good sign that we were
doing algebra correctly 1 plus sine
theta so i have one there
i have another one over here 1 plus
sine theta so that's
all over 1 plus
sine theta and because this is a proved
question rather than cancel everything
which i almost could do if i didn't know
this result that i was going to because
this is a proof question i want to make
the factorization and cancelling
really super clear so i'm going to
factorize out 1 plus sine theta
on the numerator and that leaves me with
sine theta
plus i cos theta which is looking
familiar and positive
based on what the question was that's
all divided by
1 plus sine theta so now i'm ready to
very satisfyingly cancel cancel and that
finally at long last arrives me at the
result
i was trying to prove so sine theta plus
i
cos theta as required and as you're
going to discover
this is not just a random identity or
piece of trigonometry
this particular expression we've just
written is really really fundamental
to all of our study of complex numbers